charlie morton on the mound 37 years old
he is 6'5 235 out of connecticut
he's made four starts already against
the phillies this year he's two and two
with a 306 era herrera leads off third
harper's off first here in the top of
the first inning oh two got him swinging
strike three
good 96 mile an hour sinker
first strike out of the ball game for
charlie and two down now liable to see a
lot of strikeouts tonight from these two
guys charlie's got 204 now on the season
a ball at a strike in the pitch on the
way to miller ground ball out to ozzy at
second he's got it and whip it over to
freddie freeman proud number three
so charlie gave up a couple of singles
but that's all no runs two hits no
errors and two men left zach wheeler the
georgia native not far from here and
it's the biggest start of his
major league career two balls two
strikes to solaire
and a breaking ball and a strike three
called on the inside corner
solaire is down looking what out here in
the first
ball just never really comes back that's
a good job by jt to bring it back toward
the view of the umpire freddie has
crushed the phillies all year 16 hits
seven of them homers
line drive out toward left field
mccutcheon's coming on he dives and he
makes the catch what a play by catch two
outs here in the first inning you're
just not gonna see a better play than
the philly's veteran outfielder here
gets a good jump in a rough series the
last home stand defensively for the
fills but this is an outstanding play so
now first and third no one out that
brings charlie morton up to the plate
shows bud bounced it off the plate riya
muto's got one play
and once miller ducks he's able to make
the peg to segura sacrifice for charlie
morton table set for the top of the
order second and third one out so here's
a key spot for the braves runner at
third less than two outs solaire the key
man line drive it's in for a hit one run
scores here comes dansby around third
he's gonna score
so lair makes it two to nothing new guy
same results well he talked about the
acquisitions that alex made
and here it comes in same kind of pitch
darno got
first pitch fastball up
so lair so strong pulls the hands in
beautifully
and in a game like this being able to
score first chip not just one but two
runs
big lift for this bridge team
in a row sent down by charlie morton
going back to the first inning swaying
and a mess
devastating breaking ball for morton his
fifth strikeout again they're hitting
125 against that pitch
look at how much it breaks i mean it
starts on the outer part look it ends up
all the way down in his back foot it's
one of the hottest hitters in baseball
and he just missed that pitch by a foot
ramuto over one with a strikeout
when baldwin strikes
backward came from ozzie 360 spin and a
strike what a play it's another reason
as much as you love those strikeouts
quick outs like that that's what's going
to get charlie deep into the game and
with the defense like this let him do it
charlie was smart to duck well yeah and
that look that's not an easy routine
play and ozzy makes it look routine this
is a gold glove caliber infield defense
two strikes two down or in the fourth
one two
check swing the appeal strike three
that ends the threat at the top of the
fourth inning gregorius just couldn't
help himself couldn't keep the barrel
the bat back and the two walks doesn't
haunt charlie no runs no hits no errors
and two left two nothing braves two
balls two strikes on dansby swanson
and a strike three call beautiful pitch
from wheeler strikeout number three
zach wheeler is about to throw his 58th
pitch of the night here's the pitch
swinging to miss he got him
so there's another one two three inning
for wheeler he has retired eight braves
in a row and the phil's need to find
some offense
as we head to the sixth inning tonight
in atlanta after five it's still the
braves two in the philly charlie morton
goes to work in the sixth inning
excellent line to this point five ground
outs seven strikeouts
didn't matter harper down at 97. eight
strikeouts for morton harper's swung and
missed twice
a beautiful pitch running off the plate
97 one out for riyal muto who struck out
in the first
popped him up
freddie freeman and foul ground he is
under it
two away
so no further here three balls two
strikes
there you go
right on by
strikeout number nine for morton braves
up two-nothing ace is empty for galva
safe place hitter
swing and a miss it's an even 10 for
charlie morton
instead of a double it's a strikeout
charlie morton has been dazzling two
nothing you scored thoughts on wheeler
tonight his fastball has just been
electric
swinging
that was a wicked sinker six strikeouts
for wheeler two outs here in the seven
that looked like a steve carlton slider
look at the movement on that
that's a joke i'm sorry right over the
top how many times you see a guy swing
over the top of a fastball we had a long
look into jt now has the one he wants he
winds up with a 1-2 on the way swinging
a miss he struck him out and the side is
retired a 1-2-3 finish for zach weiner
here in the seventh inning he strikes
out seven tonight what a job by charlie
morton to start for the brave seven
innings
three hits no runs couple of walks
and ten strikeouts in game one luke
jackson will start the eighth inning two
up two down for jackson so far his 16th
pitch
driven to wright solaire retreat still
going back plenty of room one two three
and out for luke jackson in the eighth
braves hold serve two nothing
so harper is aboard tying run comes to
the plate it's jt riamuto
driven toward right center field long
run and a great grab by heredia throw
back to first and harper's there safely
great read great jump great result one
out another fast ball away and jt did
not necessarily hit that ball on the
button chip a little bit out in front
and already with a great read you could
see him coming over the whole way now
they're going to give matt virelling a
chance to bat against him
and a light drive out toward left field
but it's right
oh it's off the glove of rosario was
right at him harper hustling to third
he'll get there the tying run is in
scoring position
what a scud that was wow
that just kept rising on rosario that
ball's hit so
hard it's just late getting his arm up
that is as bad a play you'll see an
outfielder make on the glove side and it
also means they're going to walk
mccutcheon intentionally so that smith
will face dede gregorius so the bases
are loaded all right so now you got
gregorius tied for the most grand slams
in major league baseball since 2017.
[Music]
line drive out to right field duvall has
it makes the catch tagging from third is
harper going to third is veerling the
phils have a run on a sac fly smith's
back to within
a strike of ending the game freddie
galvez digs in smith ready again the
payoff
struck him out graves winning 2-1
rage win game one and the magic numbers
down to three